وفي الوقت الحالي ، لا يزال دونالد ترامب في
Mar-A-Lago وهو
عمل إلى حد كبير كالمعتاد حتى في الساعات التي
أعقبت لائحة الاتهام ، حيث تناول العشاء مع
الضيوف هنا في نادي Mar-A-Lago
مع زوجته ميلانيا ترامب التي كان
يختلط بها  هؤلاء الضيوف حتى
بعد لائحة الاتهام هذه ، وبعد ذلك
بالطبع ، ذهب على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الخاصة به
وبدأ في انتقاد
المدعي العام ولكن فيما يتعلق بالأيام القليلة المقبلة
بالنسبة له ، سيتوجه إلى
مدينة نيويورك يوم الاثنين ونادي Mar-A-Lago  على بعد
حوالي 15 دقيقة من مطار بالم بيتش
الدولي ، ومن المرجح أن
يأخذ شارع Southern Boulevard وهو
الطريق الرئيسي من Mar-A-Lago إلى
ذلك المطار ، ومن المرجح أن
يصطف مع مؤيديه في
حدث كبير مثل هذا الذي يميلون إليه  يخرجون ويحضرون
أعلامهم ويلوحون
بالرئيس السابق ويطلقون
أبواقهم دعمًا له فيما يتعلق بما
سيفعله خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ، فمن المؤكد أنه
لعب الكثير من الجولف قبل صدور
لائحة الاتهام هذه ، لذا سنرى  إذا
ربما ذهب إلى أحد نوادي الجولف الخاصة به
هنا في فلوريدا ولعب بعض
الجولف وربما صفي رأسه ، وبعد ذلك
بالطبع سيكون هنا في Mar-A-Lago
حيث توجد دائمًا حفلات الزفاف
والحفلات وجميع أنواع الأحداث.
يميل إلى الاختلاط بالحشود هناك
ويفاجئ الناس حتى يظهر الزوجان اللذان كانا
يتزوجان دون سابق إنذار ، لذا
سنرى ما إذا كان الرئيس السابق في
حالة مزاجية لفعل أي شيء من هذا القبيل أم أنه
إذا قرر أن يبتعد عن راندي ك.
سي إن إن ويست بالم بيتش فلوريدا